dans un tout autre domaine celui du
cinéma et du 4k une technologie qui
permet de délivrer une image jusqu'à
deux fois supérieur à la haute
définition actuelle de nombreuses salles
s'y mettent notamment les petits cinémas
de quartier qui prennent leur revanche
face aux multiplexes qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens pour renouveler
l'ensemble de leur parc
la direction trappe et le grenier à sel
en cinéma qui aura bientôt un siècle qui
s'est offert un joli cadeau des
premières projections de 1920 à celle
d'aujourd'hui en très haute définition
le grenier à sel à trappes aura connu
toutes les évolutions technologiques du
cinéma baptisé le normandie en 1964 son
écran courbe l'heracles orama avec son
impression de relief séduit les
spectateurs depuis 2012 est sous son nom
de cinéma jean renoir c'est avec cette
diffusion des films en quatre cas qu'il
fait venir le public 4k comprenait une
définition d'image environ deux fois
supérieure à celle des télévisions full
hd de nos salons on a encore eu il n'y a
pas très longtemps là avec la sortie du
film amours de lanaken qui celui qui a
eu la balle mot d'ordre qui était en 4k
on avait des gens qui sortaient des
spectateurs qui sortait et qui était
bluffé mais c'est quoi cette image parce
que effectivement le film était
incroyable c'était la plus belle
définition qu'on a vu jusqu'à présent
jusqu'à ce qu'au fil de ce soir samsara
ça marche comment fait on va remplacer
la pellicule par un des disques durs ou
de ce qu'on appelle des dcp donc c'est
un format d'encodage qui est propre au
cinéma et on va donc chargé le disque
dur ou le contenu directement sur le
serveur et l'espace de stockage du de la
partie projection du projecteur ou alors
on peut recevoir de manière
dématérialisée par ou par satellite ou
par adsl
les films et ce sont des fichiers très
lourd on 150 gia de lourds
investissements ont été nécessaires le
projecteur avoisine les 60 mille euros
ajoutez à cela les travaux d'électricité
ou encore de ventilation et la facture
monte à 100 mille euros reste à
rentabiliser l'opération puisque les
autres cinémas s'équipent à leur tour
signer c'est à elle en cours ou salle
jacques brel à montigny le bretonneux et
c'est une nouvelle guerre entre
exploitants qui débute à celui qui
offrira le meilleur confort visuel et
auditif
sachez que si vous souhaitez rivaliser
il vous faudra mettre la main à la poche
les premiers téléviseur 4k
yves mais ils ne sont pas vraiment bon
marché le premier modèle est 1,84 pouces
qui est aux alentours de 25 mille euros
donc ce qui me paraît vraiment excessif
effectivement donc réservé
malheureusement à certains seulement
nous sortons la actuellement de
nouvelles télés de nouveaux téléviseurs
plus économique et on devrait être aux
alentours de entre 10 et 15 d'une roue
et le directeur des ventes de sony
france que vous venez d'entendre
il nous a accordé une interview afin
d'en savoir plus sur la stratégie de son
groupe pour l' écoute on se retrouve
ensuite en plateau pour la suite du 7-8
on continue donc ce focus sur cette
technologie 4k au grenier à sel à
trappes à présent avec le directeur
ventes et marketing de sony bonsoir à
vous bonsoir le public est en train de
découvrir la projection du film samsara
à votre avis qu'est-ce qui doit le plus
les interpeller les choquer interpeller
leurs yeux pendant cette projection et
vont ressortir bluffer tout simplement
tout simplement parce que ces
spectateurs ont la chance de découvrir
ce soir à magnifique film qui donc a été
entièrement tourné en argentique 70 mm
ce qui reste malgré tout aujourd'hui le
top des captations ce qui se fait de
mieux pour le monde du cinéma mais ils
ont surtout la chance de voir
me projeter le québec
projecteurs sony 4k donc en format 4k ce
qui est aujourd'hui le top de la qualité
pour les salles de cinéma la salle de
cinéma le grenier à sel a fait le choix
justement de s'équiper avec cette
technologie sony 4k est ce que beaucoup
de cinémas indépendants ou même des gros
groupes ont fait ce choix aussi où on
est le développement de la technologie
du parc alors malheureusement
aujourd'hui beaucoup de groupes de
grandes chaînes de cinéma bien connu
sont équipées en numérique certes mais
que si je puis dire en deux cas pour la
simple et bonne raison que c'est par
l'onss et cinéma se sont équipés il ya
maintenant environ à peu près les tout
premiers ont démarré il ya cinq ans et à
cette époque malheureusement le la
technologie le format 4k n'existait pas
encore et nous sommes-nous précurseur en
la matière et nous avons proposé ces
produits donc adapté pour les salles de
cinéma que il y a deux ans ce qui fait
que nous sommes un petit peu en retard
par rapport à l'équipement et à la
numérisation des salles particulièrement
en france puisque en france
aujourd'hui 90% à peu près des salles
sont équipées
ceci étant les salles qui restent à
équiper aujourd'hui où les nouvelles
salles en cours de construction ou les
projets à venir
ça ne fait aucun doute que ces
exploitants ils choisiront le format 4k
et bien évidemment je l'espère le format
4k sony sony étant
l'inventeur quelque part de cette
technologie et puis ensuite viendra le
renouvellement aussi du parc déjà
existants équipés en rang de cas sur les
autres groupes et là aussi ce sera des
parts de marché potentiel pour pour se
dire tout à fait dans la mesure où
effectivement donc la technologie évolue
très vite
au delà du 4k il ya d'autres
technologies qui ont vu le jour depuis
hfr le laser qui va voir le jour aussi
très prochainement
donc nous pensons que les exploitants
qui se sont équipés il ya maintenant
cinq ans quatre ans voire même que trois
ans malheureusement pour pouvoir
continuer à suivre l'évolution
technologique devront effectivement
changé de renouveler leur matériel est
bien évidemment à ce monde à opter pour
ce nouveau format qui lequel le 4e cas
donc je finance y est important parce
que c'est aussi ont je pense plus pour
le grand public un produit d'appel de
voir au cinéma la technologie sony 4k
vous l'avez évoqué lors de la
présentation tout à l'heure mais il ya
les téléviseurs qui arrive qui sont
commercialisés la future playstation 4
qui devrait également en 4k voilà pour
les amateurs pour les projections de
films en tout cas donc il ya un vrai
enjeu financier qu'on sonne il ya un
vrai enjeu financier il ya un vrai enjeu
économique à l'échelle mondiale on peut
faire un petit peu le parallèle avec
l'arrivée de la haute définition je pas
si vous vous souvenez mais il ya dix ans
maintenant peut-être un peu plus nous
sommes passés de la standard définition
à la haute définition
aujourd'hui tout le monde est équipé en
technologie et en format haute
définition
nous pensons que demain tout le monde
sera aussi équipé en 4k pour pouvoir
bénéficier de cette technologie
aujourd'hui dans les salles de cinéma
demain à la maison avec effectivement
une gamme de téléviseurs que nous
lançons la actuellement avec trois
produits phares
lecteur blu ray home cinéma qui est déjà
sur le marché et qui a rencontré un très
vif succès voilà pour la partie grand
public n'oublions pas également la
partie professionnelle pour ce qui
concerne la captation
donc aujourd'hui nous proposons
également des caméras donc de cinéma
numérique 4k
trois modèles donc pour pouvoir
fabriquer le film en 4k dès le départ si
je puis dire
et puis d'autres produits qui vont voir
le jour également dans le domaine
broadcast par exemple pour le grand
public ce sera abordable parce que
lorsqu'il faut renouveler changer son
équipement il faut toujours mal à mettre
la main au portefeuille et donc le
contexte économique est difficile c'est
plus compliqué c'est comme beaucoup
d'évolutions technologiques c'est vrai
que les prix peuvent peut-être paraître
un petit peu gelé dire aberrant au
départ ou inaccessibles pour tout un
chacun
ceci étant la technique évolue en les
prix bien évidemment la production
augmente les prix baissent et on parlait
à l'instant du passage de la standard
définition à la haute définition
n'oublions pas que la haute définition
quand elle est apparue sur le marché
était très très très onéreuse c'est
exactement la ddt d'user l'époque qui
étaient considérés comme trop chers
aujourd'hui tout le monde à un
téléviseur haute définition dans son
salon à un téléviseur 4,15 ça coûte
combien
aujourd'hui ça coûte ça coûte en fait il
ya toute une gamme de produits donc le
premier modèle est 1,84 pouces qui est
aux alentours de 25 p l'euro donc ce qui
peut paraître vraiment excessif
effectivement donc réservé
malheureusement à certains seulement
nous sortons la actuellement de
nouvelles télés de nouveaux téléviseurs
plus économique et on devrait être aux
alentours de entre 10 et 15 euros
une dernière question on parle de
technologie 4k les choses vous le dites
évoluer très rapidement il ya d'autres
technologies encore qui arrive derrière
ceux de travail sur autres sutra et sur
beaucoup d'autres choses maintenant en
termes de résolution je pense qu'on a
atteint là le maximum de ce que l'oeil
mas est capable de percevoir tous les
mois en terme de différence paraît de
huit cas de seize cas pourquoi pas mais
là on serait un niveau tel que
finalement le spectateur ne verrai
la différence entre le 4 et le 8 par
exemple donc ça n'a que peu d'intérêt à
notre avis nous pensons plus aujourd'hui
pour revenir sur la partie projection
cinéma à des adaptations au terme des
évolutions en termes d'exploitation en
termes d'économies de coûts pour
l'exploitant parce que n'oublions pas
que l'exploitant à un coût bien
évidemment le fonctionnement qui est
assez conséquent donc nous réfléchissons
par exemple je le disais tout à l'heure
à l'arrivée du laser pour la génération
de lumière qui a aujourd'hui on
fonctionne encore avec des lampes qui
faisait nom au type mercureaux de
pression et celle ont bien évidemment
sus très très vite et en train coûts
importants pour l'exploitant de salles
de cinéma le laser par exemple pourra
être une évolution très intéressante
qu'il a cette fois ci d'un point de vue
économique sera profitable pour pour le
professionnel qui exploite les salles de
cinéma merci à vous pour toutes ces
précisions et on se retrouve à présent
sur le plateau du 7 8 pour la suite de
cette édition du jour juste pour
conclure un sur le 4k sachez aussi qu
aux etats unis les ventes de télé ont
débuté depuis quelques jours depuis le
21 avril 4999 dollars c'est précis pour
1 55 pouces 6999 pour le 65 vous êtes
acheteuse du 4k des téléviseurs à ce
prix là encore face aux infos en plus de
cette chronique de l'écho oui aux
premières infos en plus c'est un nouveau
problème sanitaire encore en août 2008
le fournisseur castel viande a vendu des
morceaux dits soulier a maqué la
centrale d'achat de mcdonald's alors
d'après le parisien c'est sous lui
reprocher yens d'accidents de des
couples qui peuvent contaminer la viande
des produits des pratiques est
normalement interdite pour faire du
steak haché
cette affaire
rejoint celle d'une chaîne de
restaurants de flunch pour laquelle la
chaîne pardon caisse pour laquelle la
société je vais y arriver
castel viande a été fait l'objet d'un
examen d'une mise en examen
je me sens vraiment n'importe quoi pour
faire simple on ne sait pas ce qu à
damas dans nos assiettes et ça ne
s'arrange pas la communauté
d'agglomération de versailles grand parc
on va faire qu'il compte ouvrir un
nouvel hôtel d'entreprises en 2014
exactement et pas seulement le prévoit
également l'extension et l'implantation
de nouvelles zones d'activités sur la
plaine de versailles et la fiscalité
appliquée aux activités professionnelles
devraient même être revu en 2013 et puis
une balle dans la jambe à en retenir une
date alors si on doit retenir une date
c'est la concurrence pour présenter le
pacte national de la compétitivité de la
croissance et de l'emploi
il y aura notamment le préfet des
yvelines aussi les commissaires
départementaux et régionaux du
redressement productif sera donc le 29
avril s'est ouvert aux entreprises et
c'est l'occasion de poser vos questions
aux représentants de l'état
merci clair on vous retrouve jeudi
prochain la nouvelle chronique et de
l'écho le 7-8 revient demain vendredi
l'édition du week-end avec julie rocha
soirée ce lundi dès 18 heures ce sera
avec catherine mulato pour débuter la
semaine